alors là du coup on fait une diffusion
de tracts pour fabien roussel pour les
élections présidentielles donc le
candidat communiste et on s'est mis un
centre commercial à une heure où il ya
du monde qui rentre et qui sort pour
distribuer au maximum les tracts et
discuter avec les gens
bonjour monsieur mon élection
présidentielle
pour l'élection présidentielle le
candidat communiste on va augmenter le
smic réduire le temps de travail donc je
pense que vous reconnaissez dans ces
idées là mais puisque vous allez vous en
pensez quoi alors qui dit thomas
tente aussi leur faire comprendre que va
le capitalisme c'est pas naturel que ça
peut s'avérer un début ça doit avoir une
fin et que bas avec notre candidat c'est
la direction que votre ventre parce que
trop rarement des communistes à vous
intéresse non merci cette planète nous
avons voté par
les éleveurs merci et pourquoi vous
parce que je veux un grand soupir du
stalinisme dans le temps parce que je
suis un vieux et le communisme
il a tourné
je n'ai entendu
il est au marqueur quand on parle aux
gens de communisme pour eux c'est leur
évoque l'urss et sert à l'histoire du
parti communiste en france c'est la
sécurité sociale les congés payés les
grandes grèves les grandes luttes
sociales la résistance le droit de vote
des femmes ce qui poussa parti
communiste en france
je suis toujours voulu être demain mon
père et moi rares mon grand père était
marin c'est toujours un rêve que j'ai eu
c'est un bouquet quand même si précaire
parce que tu sais pas en fait quand tu
pars tu sais tu attends tu reviens je
sait pas vraiment quel point tu vas être
payés parce que souvent tu es payé à la
part en plus donc à la pêche pourquoi
c'est un métier assez précaire mais
derrière il est salaire ils sont
généralement plus élevés que la moyenne
en raison aussi des connexions de
travail beaucoup plus difficile
j'ai commencé vraiment m'investir plus
personnellement en 2017 j'ai commencé à
sentir le danger du fétichisme avec le
pen et du coup me suis un peu intéressé
est ce que c'est l antifascisme et tout
et c'est là que j'ai découvert le
communisme vraiment comme mode de
société et aussi comme manière de faire
face au fascisme il ya des gens qui
veulent du profit à court terme et qui
pour ça ils sont prêts à sacrifier la
vie de l'immense majorité de la
population
le communisme celle inverse c'est de
dire que voilà c'est ceux qui
travaillent c'est l'immense majorité qui
doit choisir pour elle même et c'est ça
le projet mon six pattes heures
[Applaudissements]
on est dans le local du parti communiste
est là comme vous pouvez le voir dans
menée dans notre rôle où il ya tous les
tracts et les affiches c'est vraiment le
lieu où tous les communistes peuvent
prendre le matériel et mettre en place
transaction pour la campagne ici là
c'est un peu notre salle des fêtes c'est
là où on fait de l'assemblée générale
nos soirées avec le bar et va comme vous
pouvez voir c'était un ancien tribunal
ici il ya encore la marianne tout en
haut et pendant la guerre d'algérie ce
avait été transformé en bureau de
conscription et du coup certains
camarades qui militait contre la guerre
d'algérie à l'époque et qui avait été
construit de force se retrouver ici pour
la visite médicale est aujourd'hui
maintenant ils occupent les locaux pour
notamment visiter sur des questions aux
impérialistes donc c'est une belle
victoire pour nous ça c'est une
reproduction
presque photoréaliste des tortues lors
de la réforme des retraites
[Musique]
là ça permet de nous afficher
dans la rue à la vue de tout le monde et
aussi d'octobre ça montre aussi
calme militants sont mobilisés ou pas
pour la campagne ainsi on voit toujours
les affiches de fabien roussel peu
importe l'endroit bah oui on peut se
dire que les équipes de fabien roussel
en fait à sont mobilisés et que c'est
des gens sérieux coup un vrai message à
porter qui y croient qu'ils veulent y
aller quoi
[Musique]
avec alain roussel on a réussi à amener
dans débat public des thèmes de pouvoir
d'achat qui font qu'aujourd'hui tous les
convives de se positionner dessus que le
débat public qui peuvent parfois tourner
autour et en fait ça c'est déjà une
victoire
propose notamment un revenu étudiants
hauteur de 850 euros qui peut aller
jusqu'à 1000 euros selon un système de
bourse ah ouais en faire on s'entend
fait que tous les étudiants puissent
étudier sans avoir à célarié à côté pour
nous c'est super important d'attirer
l'attention des jeunes surtout que
certains au parti communiste mais c'est
aussi au mouvement des jeunes
communistes de france est en fait notre
rôle s'ils pouvaient utiliser la
jeunesse parce que y'a rien qui terrifie
plus un gouvernement de droite que des
jeunes qui sortent dans la rue qui
bloquent leur lycée leur fac qui se met
pas tu as manifestées vous êtes emploi
tensions politiques pour vous
[Musique]
les programmes et tous n'ont pas encore
la droite c'est la sécurité la gauche
c'est le social alors qu'en fait non au
tibet la sécurité ça peut être de gauche
et nous on veut parler de tous ces
sujets là en y apportant notre vision et
notre vision de gauche et ça permet de
faire avancer les idées souvent ils
comprennent pas forcément pourquoi on
leur parle de politique
notre but c'est d'essayer de leur faire
comprendre que ça peut sauver leur vie
et que la jeunesse ça doit être la
priorité en fait dans toutes les
élections